the acting director of Nevada prison
speaks about The Escape of a murderer
for the very first time this morning
marking the first Board of prison
Commissioners meeting since the escape
and the former director resigned the
eight news now investigators have been
exposing major failures inside the
prison for nearly a Year Vanessa Murphy
has more on what unfolded today
the acting director of Nevada prisons
admitting staff only learned about The
Escape of a convicted murderer three and
a half days later because another inmate
had told them he admitted to security
issues and other failures and says they
are being addressed from top to bottom
the department accepts responsibility
for and truly regrets the security
breaches that allowed the escape from
our custody acting director bill gitter
says eight employees are on paid
administrative leave after the inmates
Escape last month he and his leadership
team point to new security measures and
in effort to improve Staffing while the
department has a vacancy rate of about
30 percent
to so many people and there's no answer
offenders loved ones continue to raise
concerns especially about medical care
and safety the board of prison
Commissioners oversees Nevada's prisons
attorney general Aaron Ford is one of
its three members the inmates the staff
and the families have been sounding the
alarm for months now you've been on the
board how have you tried to address
those concerns I'm not quite sure which
alarms you're talking about in
particular but as obviously as a member
of the board of commission or prison
Commissioners I am engaged with them we
hear from them and I have my staff
follow up and we do what we can to be
responsive the alarms I'm talking about
are medical concerns lack of Medical
Care safety inside the prisons along
those lines my answer remains we hear
from them we interact with them and we
try to address concerns as they are
presented to us Melissa Juna says she
feels like she's finally being heard
only after the inmates Escape because of
the scrutiny placed on the department I
think it's a start more families have
reached out I thought I was alone
I thought that maybe I was the only one
we tried asking the acting director
questions after that meeting he declined
saying he had another meeting to go to
Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now